Let's see what's on people's minds today.
We will go to the phone lines at (617) 830-4750
and we will start today with our color from
the seven seven zero area code color from
seven, seven zero.
Uh, what's your name?
Where are you calling from?
[inaudible]
seven seven zero.
I heard you shuffle
Richard's enough.
Kaylon where are you David?
Hey Richard.
What's going on?
Hello?
Yes.
What's going on?
Richard?
[inaudible]
okay.
Again here.
I'm good.
Hey.
So here's my question.
Um, so with this, let's say Senator Sanders,
um, somehow is able to actually win the nomination
and does end up wanting the presidential race.
What do you think the odds are that you will
actually get a Medicare for all bill pass?
Because it seems like even those who do support
Medicare for all have some watered down version
of it.
Like, so how many do you think would actually
vote for it if it were to be put put on the
bill for everyone to vote on?
This is a very important question, which is
that even within the democratic party, there
is not, um, sort of unanimous consent around
number one.
Not everybody in the democratic party supports
Medicare for all.
And even those that support something that
they call Medicare for all, they don't necessarily
support it in the exact way in formulation
that Bernie Sanders does.
But I don't think that this is particularly
relevant because what we've seen is that the
more, um, uh, progressive position that you
start the negotiation from, the better off
we will end up.
So Bernie Sanders can't control whether Democrats
take control of the Senate in 2020 or 2022.
Bernie Sanders can't, at least not directly
control, uh, what the majority of the democratic
majority is in the house or whether they maintain
one after the midterm.
All he can do is say, here's my starting point.
And then he will negotiate with whoever is
there for the most progressive possible plan.
So I think you're bringing up a perfectly
reasonable question, which is, is it guaranteed
that a president Bernie gets Medicare for
all?
The answer is definitely not.
Definitely not.
And this is just a reality.
I mean, it's not a pro or anti Bernie bias
thing, it's just, there's no guarantee that
any president gets done what they want to
do.
The more audacious it is, the more difficult
it will be to do.
But we still want to be starting from the
best possible place.
Right.
I do have one more follow up if you have time.
It'd be a quick question.
Um, so one of the main arguments I hear against
Medicare for all courses, how are you going
to pay for it and whatever.
Someone brings up Canada, UK off from the,
the number one, uh, pivot from, from the right
six of you.
Well, but there, you know, population is significantly
less than I was.
That's right.
They're able to, you know, have a system like
that.
So run on how to care for all at a state level
instead of a national level would actually
be any better.
Um, just be [inaudible] it seems like it would
be a little easier to manage, or at least
it's the way I see it right now.
So I dealt with this earlier this week, so
I won't, I won't do the full explanation,
but, so two things on that.
Number one, I disagree with the premise that
if you have more people, it's more difficult
to do because more people actually means that
the, the risk pool is larger and no one group
within that population is going to throw off
your actuarial predictions, um, nearly as
much.
So I reject that on principle.
That being said, I have no problem with Medicare
for all or other single payer systems starting
at the state level.
I think that from a pragmatic perspective,
you might much more quickly be able to get
something done.
So I'm not opposed to it in any way, but the
population argument is a tired one.
[inaudible]
gotcha.
Thank you David.
Appreciate the time.
All right, Richard.
Yep.
Gonna let you go.
Uh, thank you for the call.